president donald trump has announced  that he has tested positive for  coronavirus donald trump removed his  mask and what i guess was supposed to be  framed as some kind of act of  some very bad courage in that group but  you also had people that were  very fine people on both sides the trump  administration is also scaling up the  number of children that are going to be  held in these internment style camps  right and then i see the disinfectant  where it knocks it out  in a minute  one minute and is there a way we can do  something like that  by  injection and we're going to the capital  usa  [Music]  we love you you're very special